Drake was back courtside for Game one of
the NBA Finals in Toronto and he was
definitely getting under the skin of the
Golden State Warriors but here's the
problem that Drake had so take a look at
this pic of Drake okay
if you look on his left arm there he
actually has a tattoo of Steph Curry's
jersey number with the word gifted
underneath and it's Kevin Durant's
jersey number tattooed right beside he's
a big fan of these guys but now yes
they're up against this Toronto Raptors
yes so what does Drake do he wears a
sweater over the top of the two numbers
that are tattooed last night and he wore
a signed Dell curry Jersey which I
thought was brilliant della Steph's a
father who played with the Raptors from
1999 to 2002 do we have that bureau love
Drake with the jersey because that's
where we can see the wrist yeah so so
yeah you can see how this weapon and
yeah you can see the sweat pan on his
arm covering up the two tattoos and yeah
so this is the Jersey buggy man yeah
it's signed on the back there so that's
the Jersey that he wore Dell curry had a
signed jersey so that's Steph Curry's
dad he is an amazing player I understand
yes a tattoo but that's funny that he
put a little banner round to cover up oh
that's funny now he did trade words with
Steph
yeah take a look look at this moment
last night I think we need a lip-reader
okay hope you like me I don't like you
do like me no I don't like you either
we're gonna wait okay yeah then you
helped somebody take some lint that's
hair I can't believe you didn't punch
him for touching his hair I know what
you wonder like what is Jay doing like
what's he going when he touches you said
hey you got some lid back there helping
you yeah yes well then
Drake when on this Instagram afterwards
did this post he said Steph Curry hair
lint
for sale on my eBay right now username
draymond shouldn't wear 23 Drake seems
to be a bit more playful with Steph but
there seems to be a real beef between
him and drove on take a look at what
happened between the two of them right
after the final whistle was blown in
Toronto when Toronto on the game
[Applause]
now you saw some talking there between
Drake and draymond Green he actually
says trash yeah actually calls him trial
he cause Drake trash no I think if we
played again I'm thinking Reid bracelets
that he says your chances I just walking
away he says I think he says trash trash
please Steph Curry is like Steph Curry
smiling exactly you know what
everything's Toronto smirk sweet people
are good people even when people were at
their hotel and they were saying things
are saying you're just having a bad day
look they were really nice or just
Christy nothing so it's nice a Drake is
stepping it I love drag being on the
side and just pushing me over you know
this is great entertainment and he's our
ambassador so why not now draymond was
asked about this in the press conference
after the game oh boy a problem with
this response just wanted you to talk a
little bit about that postgame scuffle
between you and Drake you got a question
about basketball and what really a
scuffle cuz I didn't hit him and he
didn't hit me or I didn't push him and
he didn't push me we talked we barked a
little bit but I wouldn't necessarily
consider that a scuffle not really what
I personally will consider a scuffle
okay sure the word scuffle isn't the
right one but I have a big problem with
him like calling around for not a single
basketball question if you want to make
it just about the game dream on don't go
up to Drake and talk to him good point
very good if you really if you're gonna
go talk to Drake you got to be expected
that someone's gonna ask you buddy
you're bringing Drake into the game by
going and talking to him you can't be in
a press conference dreaming and call it
a reporter and say why do you not asking
me about basketball because you didn't
make it a question afterwards he was
being a little
not a nice guy right but at least he
answered a question after yeah I agree
maybe scuffle was the wrong that's the
wrong word in my world in Canadian world
that's a sculpture we apologize if we
even say just say anything so no it's
you know yes I think Jerry munch is just
ignored Drake Rob says Drake serves no
purpose no yeah this is I love it go
Drake yeah it Rob's is zero respect for
Drake Chantal says I love it pulses I
love it Dinah says that's not on Drake
that's on the media I was at games
it would be worse they deserve support I
know what it says I love the curry
laughs yeah looked at trolls like no
sorry these some of these answers don't
them because since and says that was a
great answer to the question yeah I mean
that's thing if you tell it's getting
under their skin it's great I dream on
boy do that to the Warriors they
actually play better when you get under
their skin all day long is he lost
yesterday which is amazed because that's
what what is known for us to be if you
do that they do extra better especially
in the third fourth quarter but last
night was just amazing to see siakam do
his thing he's first time in the
playoffs first time in the finals it was
so wonderful to see Canada come together
there was Jurassic Park and every song
before we were even in Mississauga there
was 20,000 people out there is just
bringing Canada together and Americans
together as I know it's great